muchos comercios son que la clave es que
opina mucha es un distrito pero también
hay zonas residenciales muy pobladas que
están a 15 kilómetros del noroeste de
donde estamos esta noche con georg en el
centro de quiero de hecho es la clave
para el sitio de kiev pues se sabe que
el este y el norte están casi totalmente
cercados por las fuerzas rusas
del west of existence world sobre el ipc
afecte comer todo lo que está en juego
hoy es la entrada desde el oeste por
donde pudieron pasar combatientes y
fuerzas especiales ucranianas también
francotiradores que intentan retardar la
entrada de los tanques rusos la presión
militar es fuerte el fin es una ciudad
grande que normalmente está habitada por
decenas de miles de residentes hemos
visto una vez más estas escenas
terribles en el país a las puertas de
europa familias desesperadas agotadas en
llanto que atraviesan la última barrera
que separa la parte de espn controlada
por los rusos de la parte donde
estábamos nosotros que todavía está
controlada por las fuerzas ucranianas y
las fuerzas de autodefensa superan jana
hecho que toco
en mi caso son 1500 personas que vienen
de todos los oficios de todas las
generaciones y que decidieron permanecer
aquí y tomar las armas y además está el
torrente de refugiados que siguen
huyendo desesperadamente de estos
combates irving como dije es una ciudad
muy residencial donde todavía se ven las
cicatrices de lo que era la vida normal
en esta otra nia en las puertas de
europa desarrollada pudimos circular con
combatientes muy cerca de las primeras
posiciones rusas pero los tanques rusos
que veíamos apenas a una centena de
metros y había cadáveres en plena calle
pero nadie podía ir por ellos porque
había francotiradores rusos también al
alcance de la vista una situación en la
que resulta muy difícil penetrar en
estas zonas en el distrito de busca muy
cerca de irving también hay intentos
desesperados de evacuación de civiles
porque sin duda habrá combates muy
pronto según nos dicen las fuerzas
ucranianas el 70% de lucha ya está en
manos de las fuerzas rusas
donde estábamos el 50 está tomado por
los rusos el otro 50% sigue en manos de
los ucranianos
el problema para terminar es que todo
esto es el acceso capital tan importante
simbólico y estratégico a quien
estábamos en este momento aquí todos
saben que la única ambición de las
fuerzas rusas estaba lanzarse sobre esta
ciudad y si cualquier
falso
timón 65 de facciones o nunca y no
visión de defensa civil el sitio de kiev
es inminente en cuestión de días quizá
pero viendo la ofensiva de hoy viendo
las explosiones que oímos durante todo
el día y el grado de destrucción de
irvine que está a 15 km de donde estamos
nada de esto presagia lo mejor en todo
caso se puede pensar que la toma de kiev
la capital ucraniana ocurrirá pronto
universia capi moi sí